ROBERT KUBIS: Hello, everyone.
Thank you for tuning in for
our Cloud On Air sessions.
Today we have three
sessions, and I
have the honor to do the
first one about Cloud Spanner.
After me will be a session about
storage, Google Cloud Storage,
and then thereafter
about G Suite hardening,
security hardening.
I'm Robert Kubis.
I'm a Cloud Developer Advocate
on the Google Cloud Platform.
We understand our job
as a bidirectional job
between the developers
that build on Google Cloud
Platform and the developers
that build the platform for you.
What are we going
to talk today about?
Today I'm going to do an
introduction on Google Cloud
Spanner.
I will start off with
what Cloud Spanner is
and where it comes from.
I'm going to talk about how it
works, like, behind the scenes.
I'm going to give you
a small demo of how
you can get started on
Google Cloud Platform
and on Cloud Spanner.
And at the end, I'm going
to talk a little bit
about some use cases and
industries and protocols
where you can use Cloud Spanner.
All right, so lets get started.
So what is Cloud Spanner?
Imagine the scenario is that
you have an application that
grows over time.
It gets viral, and a lot
of people are using it.
And this system is backed
by a relational database.
So for instance, you
have billing data
or any kinds of things like
payments and things like that.
At some point, you would
need to scale your database
to cope with the traffic
that you are getting.
So you have two options.
You basically look
at either scaling
up your relational database,
but this has ceiling, right?
Like, you basically have to
wait for your cloud provider
to provide a bigger machine
or for your hardware vendor
to provide a bigger
machine, and then you
have to move everything over.
Very, very complicated.
The other option is that if you
outgrow your vertical scalable
solution, you are looking
at other solutions which
are scaling horizontal.
So you are looking
usually at NoSQL databases
where you scale horizontally.
But by scaling horizontally
and going the NoSQL way,
you're giving up some
really, really nice features
about relational databases.
So in between
these two, you have
something that is called
charting where you can
chart a relational database.
But you give up a
lot of the qualities
as well for the
relational database.
And it gets really,
really complicated.
So we actually were faced
with exactly that problem
here in Google.
Our ads business was
running on a sharded MySQL,
and we needed to
find a solution which
enables us to scale at the rate
we were scaling and growing
the company without
having interruptions,
without taking down
the entire database.
You can imagine, like,
Google is a 24/7 business.
And we cannot afford basically
taking our system offline
for maintenance,
for schema upgrades,
or for migrating from
one system to another.
So after we had our system
sharded for many, many years,
and the last shard
took two years,
we built actually
a new system which
was giving us these
attributes that we are looking
for-- a system that
can scale horizontally,
is globally distributed,
and strongly consistent.
So please meet Cloud Spanner.
Cloud Spanner is
actually the system
that we are using
inside of Google.
So Cloud Spanner we have used
for many, many years inside
of Google.
And we now make it
available as a product,
as a fully-managed product,
under the Google Cloud Platform
umbrella.
So just to recap,
what are the features
of Google Cloud Spanner?
It is an enterprise-grade
database.
It is globally distributed.
It is strongly consistent.
We don't sacrifice
anything there.
And you combine the benefits
of a relational database
with the horizontal scale.
So you get a lot of
the features that you
are familiar with from
a traditional relational
database.
So things like
ACID transactions,
things like the
Structured Query Language,
and you get also
an SLA from us that
is up to five nines of uptime.
So this is about 23
seconds per month
that we allow as downtime.
So many questions
that we get asked are,
like, how does
Google Cloud Spanner
compare to either
traditional databases--
traditional
relational databases--
or to the more new or modern
ones, the nonrelational,
so-called NoSQL databases?
So you here see a
table where we compare
a couple of the attributes
of these two databases.
And I want to start with
relational database.
As we saw in the first scenario,
like in a relational database,
you basically--
you can only scale vertically.
You can add main memory, you can
add disk, and you can add CPU.
But at some point, you
reach a scalability ceiling.
And if you want to stay
relational, what you had to do
is basically shard your
relational database.
So you basically
say, OK, I'm going
to have part of
this table there,
part of this table
on a second database.
And then you pull out
all the nice features
from relational database,
like ACID transactions
and referential
constraints, and you
have to re-implement these
things in your application.
So its a lot, a lot of things
that you have to deal with.
And it's a lot of
operational overhead.
So basically, if you look at
a relational database system,
it's not really
scalable, in a sense.
It's really difficult to scale.
Now, a lot of companies,
they went like, OK,
scalability is something
I cannot sacrifice on.
I need a scalable database.
So they went the NoSQL way.
NoSQL has a lot of nice things.
You have more structure
flexibility in your schemas.
And you can actually
distribute it under, like,
through many, many nodes
and horizontal scaling.
But none of these
traditional NoSQL databases
have actually a
strong consistency
across multiple
regions and is still
usable in the sense of
that it has low latency.
Of course, databases,
NoSQL databases,
where you can tweak
the consistency model
and can decide how much
consistency you want
to have for your
queries, but still, it's
really, really complicated
and usually it gets very slow
if you want to have a
very strong consistency
for your NoSQL databases.
Now, the other thing
is replication.
For the traditional
database system,
you can replicate to
multiple instances
and then use these
instances, for instance,
for read-only replica, by
then freeing up your master
node from some read performance
that it usually uses up,
and then can actually
use more rights
or do more rights
on your master node.
So how does Cloud
Spanner actually work?
I want to start with a
logical architectural overview
of our Cloud Spanner.
So you start with Cloud
Spanner with an instance.
So an instance is basically
your resource pool,
your compute nodes,
and your storage.
And in this instance,
you can create databases.
So you can create, I think,
about 1,024 databases
and then about 2,000 tables
in each of your databases.
All these databases and
tables live in this instance.
So this is your
resource pool, and you
can create multiple databases.
Now, this is
something that you are
familiar with from a
relational database.
Now, there is another
structure which is somewhat
hidden from you, but
we talk about it,
and that is actually splits.
So splits are basically
where we take a table
and order it by your
primary key alphabetically
or lexicographically, and then
we take ranges off your table
and split it by ranges.
And that enables this
really, really cool thing
in Cloud Spanner.
So what are we doing with this?
So as mentioned, you
get with an instance
a resource pool of
compute nodes and storage.
Now, what we can do is
basically we replicate all this
in multiple zones
and by that get
a high availability and also
some scalability in terms
of read that we can perform.
Now, to get high read
and write throughputs,
we actually use these
splits and distribute them
across the computes
that are available.
And by that, we have
multiple computes
basically being able to
manage reads and writes.
So what we have
here, you can see
as we separate the compute and
storage, we have three zones.
So this is a schematic
for a regional instance.
Now, in my regional instance
here, I choose three nodes.
So I have three nodes
replicated to all three zones.
So in total, you get
nine compute nodes.
Now, what is really important
for these splits or these parts
of your table, these ranges, is
that there is exactly and never
more than one compute node
responsible for a split.
And we do this by using Paxos.
So we use basically,
here in this example,
I have the split one.
I have in each zone
one compute node
who is responsible
for that split one.
And then from these
three nodes that
are responsible for split
one, I need to pick a leader.
So here in this
case, we use actually
Paxos, which is a
consensus algorithm
to choose a leader
in this group.
But as I mentioned, it's
really, really important
that we never have two
leaders for a split.
So how do we do that
actually performantly?
And that's where True
Time is coming in.
So you see, True
Time is something
that we invented inside Google
to be able to have something
like a global wall clock time.
So let me talk a little
bit more about True Time.
So True Time is basically
what we do all over the world
globally in our data centers.
We have GPS and atomic clocks.
And what we need actually
is we need something
that we can trust
all around the world.
So let me give you an example.
Imagine you have
your friend with you,
and you compare watches, and
you synchronize these watches.
And then you went off, and
you meet again after a week,
or let's say a month.
Your watches will have drifted.
Let's assume it's
not a smartwatch that
resynchronizes by itself.
Let's have one of these
old analog watches, right?
So they will drift
from each other.
And this drift is actually
dangerous in the sense of--
if I trust these logs, I have
actually two different times
in two different places.
And by that, I could have
two leaders for a split
and get inconsistency.
So we needed something
that we actually
can trust all around the world.
So we invented True
Time, which gives you
actually not a specific
time, but it gives you
a range of time.
It gives you an upper
and a lower bound
for a time that is
either passed or not
passed all around the world.
So let me be a little
bit more concrete here.
So True Time
basically quantifies
the worst possible error or
drift between data centers.
You get a lower bound.
That lower bound defines
that this timestamp
has passed all over the world.
And you get an
upper bound, which
is a timestamp that has
passed nowhere in the world.
Now, with these
two timestamps, you
can actually make sure
that you have never
more than one leader for a
split, which is really, really
cool.
So to synchronize actually
our atomic clocks,
we use GPS time masters
in our data centers.
These are synchronizing
our atomic clocks.
And then these atomic
clocks, basically when
we get a True Time for
Spanner, but also other use
cases in the Google
Cloud Platform,
we ask a subset of time
masters-- so the GPS
time masters and atomic clocks.
And then if there's any
outlier, we just say, like, OK,
this is a bad time master.
We don't trust it.
We take it out.
But basically, since we have
a subset of this time master,
we basically take
the majority of that.
Now, in the normal operation,
these atomic clocks
drift by about 50
microseconds per second or 200
microseconds per second,
and we resynchronize them
about every 30 seconds.
Now, some of you
might ask, like,
what happens if all our
time masters go down
in the data center?
Now, we can actually
ask True Time timestamp
from a different data
center, and we just
calculate in the
latency it takes
to travel to this
other data center
and get the True Time timestamp.
What that means is the epsilons
or the range between the upper
and lower bound gets bigger.
And by that, the database
will actually slow down,
but it will not stop.
It will still be operational.
So what is the data format
in Google Cloud Spanner?
The data format is actually
what you are very familiar with.
We are using for Google
Cloud Spanner SQL and Z2011
with a couple of extensions.
So you can use
just the normal DDL
as you are familiar with from a
traditional relational database
and create your schemas.
So here in this example, I have
a singers table and an album
table.
And I just create
that with strong types
string or integer and things
like define primary keys.
Now, there is a feature, since
this is a distributed database,
there are a couple of
things that are not
available in Google
Cloud Spanner compared
to a traditional
database system, things
like referential constraints.
But we have something where
you can optimize your access
patterns.
And that is something
that we call interleaving.
So this is a technique to
basically physically interleave
child tables into parent tables.
By that you gain data locality.
So you can actually group
data together and make sure
that queries, if you do
joins a lot on the parent
table and the child table,
that these queries can
be answered by one node or
only very few subset of nodes.
All right, so how
does it look like?
How can you actually create
interleaved data tables?
Here, in this example,
we have our singers table
that we saw from
the example before,
and then we have
the albums table,
and you just say, like,
interleaved fingers.
What's really important here is
that you share the primary key
of your parent table.
That is really important so
that the interleaving actually
works.
I want to tell you--
be a little bit
careful with this.
Interleaving means
that all the data
in your parent table and child
table end up in one split.
We talked about splits earlier.
One split is managed
by one compute node.
So if you have one row
in your parent table,
all the stuff, like all the
data from your interleave table
that qualifies for this primary
key ends up in the same split.
So if you have a
large child table
onto one row of
your parent table,
you might run into limits of
read/write capacity and also
storage capacity.
So be a little bit careful
there, especially also
for scalability reasons.
A really, really cool
feature about Cloud Spanner,
which was really
important for us
when we adopted it
inside of Google,
was that we have no
downtime schema changes.
So what you can do with
Google Cloud Spanner,
you can actually
alter your table,
add tables, add indexes
without any downtime.
And I'm going to show you
that in a second as well.
All right, so how
can you actually get
started with Google
Cloud Spanner?
So your first stop will be
cloud.google.com/spanner.
So this is our entry
page or the page
where you can go in and
learn about Cloud Spanner.
You have links to the
docs, but you find also
a lot of the things that
I just talked about,
like comparison
between Cloud Spanner
and traditional databases
as well as NoSQL databases.
We talk about use cases,
and you find all the way
to the bottom also some use
cases and studies around Google
Cloud Spanner.
So I really can recommend
to read the Quizlet Blog.
If you're coming from a
charted MySQL database,
you want to know how
Quizlet did the D
charting into Cloud Spanner.
This is a really good blog,
of course, very technical.
All right, so you get started
in the Google Cloud Platform
console.
So console.cloud.google.com.
And there this is this home
scheme that you see here.
Now, they have multiple
options to go to Cloud Spanner.
You either use the
Search box in the top.
You can actually go to the
Search bar by hitting slash,
as you might be
familiar from WIM.
But you can also use the
hamburger symbol here
in the left upper corner
and then go to Spanner.
You find it's somewhere
in our drawer.
You go to Spanner,
and there it is.
I have already one
instance created
I'm going to talk
about in a second.
But let's create
an instance first.
So you click on Create Instance.
You give it a name.
You say cloud on air.
It fills in the instance
ID automatically.
You can change it if you want.
Then you have the
opportunity to choose
between a regional or
multi-regional instance.
So regional is basically
a Cloud Spanner instance
distributed across three
zones in one region.
Multi-regional gives
you the opportunity
to distribute your
Cloud Spanner instance
across multiple regions, up to
a global configuration where
you have the read/write
replicas in the US,
and then you have
read-only replicas,
for instance, in
Europe and in Asia.
So we're going to choose
and use US-central1 here.
You see also on the right
side what the US-central1
configuration is, like
all the API names,
replicas, how many
replicas you get.
Our SLA for a regional instance,
it is four nines of SLA.
And to be qualified
for the SLA, you
need to at least have
three nodes running.
So I'm going to do
three nodes here.
You're going to see what the
cost is per hour for the nodes
and then also the storage cost.
You click Create, and
within seconds literally
you get your own instance.
Now you can start and create
your database here and create
a schema and
everything, but I want
to show you how to do
this programmatically.
So let's switch over to
my IntelliJ instance.
And I'm going to show
you how to get started.
So I choose for this session
to show you the Java client.
So to get started
with the Java client,
you have to either
use Gradle or Maven.
In this case, I
use Maven POM file.
And you basically select the
Google Cloud Spanner Client
Library for Java, currently
in version 0.34 0 beta.
You have to import also
to Guava Library and then
the Google authentication
to authenticate
against Cloud Spanner.
So it's actually very
simple to get authenticated.
If you run your client
on a GC instance
or from your laptop, which
is set up with G-Cloud, which
is our SDK, which comes
with a CLI and everything,
you can actually use the
authentication context
of either your GCE
instance or your laptop
that is already authenticated.
So I'm authenticated against
my project with my laptop.
And to use the
authentication there,
I just do google.credentia
l.getapplicationsdefault.
One line.
All right.
I captured some exceptions
here, but basically it's
one line you authenticated.
Great.
So next thing that I need is I
need the instance in my project
that I want to talk to
and the database that I
want to talk to.
So here in this case, I
talk about Spanner Cloud
and the instance
that I just created.
And I'm going to create a
database with the name demo.
So let's jump into
Create Database.
So for the Create
Database, we basically
have to get a
database admin client.
So we get that from
our Spanner library.
You get the database
admin client,
and we say, what
is the instance ID?
I filled that in
through this function,
and I want to also
know the database ID.
So what you see here
is I actually create
a database in that instance with
the-- so in my Spanner Cloud
OnAir instance, with
the database name demo,
and then I define the
DDL here-- so the schema.
And I recommend everybody,
like, if the first schema
that you create
with your database,
create it right away
with your database.
If you create it after your
database, it will take a while.
Schema changes are not as
fast as queries and things
like that, so they can
take up to minutes.
And depending on if
you create indexes
that need to be backfilled,
it can take hours or days.
So here in my case, I'm
creating an account table
with three columns--
account ID, name, and email--
and I create an address table.
And I interleave all of this.
So with this interleaving,
I do the co-location,
and I also have that one
feature that actually
can do a delete cascade.
So if I delete the
parent row, I actually
can make sure that
all the addresses
in my address table for that
parent are deleted as well.
So let me run this.
This should take only
a couple of seconds.
Now, the set up of the client
takes a couple of seconds.
So this is not like
coming back right away,
but you see down here
that it actually finished.
So we can go back and check
if our instance actually
was created.
And we see we have
our demo database.
All right, very cool.
So now, with this
demo database, I
can do things like I
can see the schema.
You see down here that
I show the schema.
I see my indexes.
I can run queries.
I'm going to show in a second.
And I can inspect these queries.
See query plan, see
where is time spent,
optimize my queries,
things like that.
I also have features in the
console where you can actually
directly add data in
the Cloud Console.
So if you want to insert data,
edit data, or delete data,
you have the possibility to do
that directly from the console.
Especially good if you do some
testing, things like that.
All right, so we have
created the database.
So let's go back to
our Java program.
And the first thing
that I'm going to do,
I insert some data.
So let's go to the Insert.
What you can see here is we are
creating a list of mutations.
So mutations are basically where
you group any kinds of changes
for the database together.
So in this case, I'm bolding
actually insert mutations,
where I insert a bunch of
data into my account table
as well as in my address table.
I want to point out one thing.
I'm using here an ID which
I declared as string 32.
And that's nothing else.
And I use UID version 4
and then convert it to hex.
And by that, I basically
have a string of 32 byte.
So why do I use UID?
In a distributed
database, you don't
want to use something
that is monotonically
increasing or decreasing.
The reason is that we
split the tables by ranges
by primary key, and if you have
something that is monotonically
increasing or decreasing, you
always end up in the first
or in the last bit, by that
overloading the node that
is responsible for that split.
So if you want to
get the best out
of your instance, the
best out of Cloud Spanner,
you want to distribute your
load as best as possible.
So that's why I'm using a
UID as a primary key here.
So let's run this,
and we're going
to go back and see if this
data was actually created.
So now in my address table, I
should be able to go to Data,
and you see that
I have some data.
OK, great.
The next thing that I want to
do is I want to do a read-only.
So in my read-only,
what I do is I create
actually read-only query.
This doesn't create any logs.
In this case, I'm just
selecting the name and an email
from my account
data and check where
the country is in Germany.
So let's see if I actually
have some data in there that
is from Germany.
So let me run this.
Really, to point out
here what is important
is that this, like, you
declare a single use
read-only transaction.
By that, we know that
this can be log free.
So we don't need to
acquire any logs.
As you can see down here, I
have two users in my database
that are living in Germany.
The next thing that I want to
show is read-write transaction.
So in a read-write transaction,
this is a little bit more
complicated.
So in Spanner Client in the Java
Library Client, what we provide
is actually the rerunning of
transactions if they fail.
And we do this by providing
a runnable transaction,
runnable so to say.
So what we do here
is we're creating
a read-write transaction, and we
provided a transaction runner.
And in this transaction
runner, I do my transaction.
So what I'm doing here
is I'm executing--
I'm running a select statement,
checking for all accounts that
have my email address,
and then updating
the name in that account.
And then I bundle this together
and send it to the transaction.
So if I run this, this
should change my data.
We can have a look
at the account,
if there is anything
changed to spanner.guru.
And as you can see here,
we have the name change
to spanner.guru.
All right, so one
note to the mutations,
mutations are important to
know about because there's
a limit in Cloud Spanner.
So Cloud Spanner has a
limit of 20,000 mutations
per transaction.
But what is a mutation in this
context of the 20,000 limit?
Mutation is actually
any change on a cell
level in Cloud Spanner.
So as an example, if I have
a table with five columns,
and I insert a
row in this table,
then I have five mutations.
Now, if I define an index
on that table, which
indices another row, or
let's say another two rows,
and I insert a
row into my table,
then it's actually
eight mutations, right?
So be aware of that.
If you see the
limit of, like, you
reach 20,000 mutations
per transaction,
that this is not 20,000 rows.
It is actually rows multiplied
by how many columns in the row
plus indices that you have.
Last but not least,
I'm going to clean up,
but I'm going to do that later.
All right, one thing that I
wanted to show you really quick
is I have actually
example database here.
And that example
database does not--
like, it's imitating like
a ticket sales platform.
Imagine a global ticket
seller who sells tickets
to events all over the world.
We did this test with a database
of 80 terabytes of data.
So something that wouldn't
fit in a traditional database.
And we did the test
also with transactions
to a limit that wouldn't fit
in a traditional database.
Now, I have a little smaller one
here, but I want to show you,
this is a query to get
actually seat availability
of all events that are happening
today from 9:00 AM, when
this cloud session started--
the Cloud OnAir
session started--
to tomorrow at 5:00 AM.
And then I'm looking for all
the events that are happening,
and I'm also checking how
many seats are available
and how many seats are available
in total and things like that.
So what is remarkable
about this create,
you don't have to think
about charting or anything.
This is just a query
how you would see it
in a traditional database, no
specialties about charting,
or things like
that, distribution.
This is all handled for you.
And you can also, right
here in the console,
get an explanation of your
query, see the query plan,
see how many rows were scanned,
how much time was spent.
And you can optimize the
query with this information.
So it's really, really powerful.
So the last couple
of minutes, let
me talk a little bit about
use cases in these industries
and verticals.
So where does Cloud Spanner
help meet business goals?
There are three
things that are really
important to mention here.
So one thing, as we
saw, Cloud Spanner
uses traditional
tools in the sense
of what you are familiar with
from traditional databases.
So it has SQL.
It has ACID transactions.
So you don't need this logic in
your application layer, things
like that.
So you can actually tap
into existing resources.
Developers that are familiar
with relational database,
they have a very easy
transition to Cloud Spanner.
Another thing is with Cloud
Spanner out of the box,
you get performance and
scale and high availability.
The way that Cloud Spanner is
set up, it is high available
and has disaster recovery
mechanisms built in.
You don't have to
worry about that.
All of this is done by us.
Up to five nines that
we provide for that.
We have regional and
multiregional instances,
low latency
transactions, and reads.
And as mentioned,
simplified operation fully
managed for you,
a couple of clicks
and you're set up
with your own instance
that you can interact
with, where you can
write data and read data from.
So what are a couple
of business use cases
that you can look into?
We look at four
main categories here
or themes I want
to talk about here.
So the first one is
transactional consistency
over a database that
is growing a lot.
So imagine you
have a supply chain
management or an
Ecommerce platform,
and you have a lot of data
that you put in your database.
So you outgrow basically
on the storage side
your traditional
database systems.
Now, what you can do is, we
talked about this charting
or go NoSQL, but you lose
the transaction consistency
or have it really,
really difficult
and have to build it into
your application, which
is very outgrown.
A second one is scale
for reads and writes.
So imagine you have a telecom
or a billing gaming company that
does all kind of actions that
are happening on your gaming
platform or, for instance,
for a telecom company,
like all kinds of calls
that are going on need to go
into a transactional system.
Now, usually where
you top out on
is like the reads and
writes that you can
do on your relational database.
Spanner, the way it is set
up, scales horizontally
for your reads and writes.
So you get some
consistency and scale
for reads and writes for that.
Another use case that we see,
or theme, is global data.
Just imagine you
have something where
you want to have the
data all over the world.
You are a global
company, and you
want to have access to your
data from all over the world.
And again, you want to have
a consistent view on this.
Imagine, like
financial services,
like banks that are operating
globally or insurances
or global call centers
that need actually
a few which are consistent
all over the world.
And the third one is
database consolidation,
just think like logistics
or manufacturing
where you have the
supply chain again,
and you want to consolidate the
data from multiple data sources
into one database.
Again, to have a strong
consistent view on this,
but also the ease
of use because you
have only one system
that you have to manage
and to deal with for your
data and your applications.
I want to close out
with a little bit step
out and do an overview of
where Cloud Spanner fits in
in the Google Cloud
Database Portfolio.
So I talked about Cloud
Spanner and all the goodies
that Cloud Spanner
comes with, but we
understand that there are other
use cases where other databases
are more suitable.
So if you look on the left, you
have our App Engine Memcache,
which is good for mobile
development and app
dev, things like that.
We have our relational where
talked about Cloud Spanner
just now, and we have Cloud SQL
which is a traditional database
system in the flavors
of MySQL or Postgres,
where you can scale vertically.
It is managed, again, you
manage for you read replicas,
and we can also do
master-master replication.
This is good for
applications where
you are good with a
vertical scalable system,
and maybe you
transition or might
create a system which
was running before
under MySQL Postgres.
We have also our
nonrelational flavors.
So you can look at
Cloud Datastore, which
is a document-based database.
It's very scalable.
Big companies that are
well known around the world
have built on Cloud Datastore
and have scaled from a couple
users to millions, hundreds
of millions of users,
on Cloud Datastore.
We have Cloud Bigtable,
which is backing our search.
For very fast reads and writes,
you can use Cloud Bigtable.
It is a row-based database.
So you have transactions on row
level but not across row level.
And then we have Cloud Storage,
which is for our plop storage,
so to say.
With Cloud Storage, we
have different tiers
based on how often
you access the data.
You can save some
money on there.
Or this really
cool Cloud Storage
is also backed by Cloud Spanner.
So if you do an LS on
Cloud Storage in the US
and in Europe, you
always get the same view.
So all data that you
commit to Cloud Storage,
be it a video file
or any other file,
you will get a consistent
view on the data
that is in Cloud Storage.
And last but not least,
really, really amazing product
is our BigQuery product, which
is our OLAP, so Data Warehouse
product, where you can load
terabytes and petabytes of data
into BigQuery and query it in
minutes or seconds or minutes
actually.
Very, very powerful, like
very powerful queries,
you have UDFs in BigQuery
that you can use.
So please try it out.
If you want to do
any data analytics
have a look at BigQuery.
And with this, I want to close.
For a second, we're going to
switch into the Q&A session
after we regroup a little bit.
So please stay tuned.
We will get back with the
questions that you asked.
So we have on the right
side, you should see the Q&A
platform, where you are able
to actually put questions in,
and we're going to answer a
couple of those in a minute.
Thank you very much.
All right.
Hello, back.
We got a couple of really cool
questions from the audience.
So I'm going to go through them.
You should see
them on the screen.
And I'm going to go
through them one by one.
So the first
question that we have
is what's the difference
between MySQL Postgres
or other relational
databases and Spanner?
So if you look at
traditional databases,
a relational database
like MySQL, Postgres,
or any of the big
vendor databases,
they are by default a
vertical scalable system.
Cloud Spanner, on
the other hand,
is a horizontally
scalable system
without giving any
of the nice criteria
up from a relational database.
So we have strong consistency.
We have asset
transactions in Spanner.
But we are
horizontally scalable.
So you can load terabytes,
hundreds of terabytes, of data
into our database.
You can have millions of reads
and writes with Cloud Spanner.
So that is the main difference
from Cloud Spanner and MySQL.
The second question was,
is it possible to migrate
from current SQL systems
like MySQL to Cloud Spanner?
It is definitely possible to
migrate, but I have to say,
like this is not to lift
and shift migration.
So because Cloud Spanner
is a distributed system,
there are some
things to be aware of
and that need to
be considered when
migrating from a MySQL system.
So one of the things is we are
currently not supporting UDF,
so User Defined Functions,
triggers, or stored procedures
on Cloud Spanner.
So if you use any
of this, you need
to re-implement these things
in an application layer.
But you get all the scalability,
and an ACID transaction
on Cloud Spanner.
Other than that,
you can currently
migrate from SQL systems by
using our Client Libraries.
So you export from
your existing database
and then create a
schema, modify the schema
to be suitable for the
distributed system,
and then load your data into
Cloud Spanner and run it there.
The third question was, why
not just use NoSQL database?
One thing, consistency.
So if you look at normal
traditional NoSQL databases,
then the first thing that
you give up is consistency.
Most of the NoSQL databases,
to achieve the scalability
and the high availability,
they are giving up
strong consistency.
So many of these systems
are eventual consistent,
and what that means
is, as an example,
you have the World
Cup, and the World Cup
is published to a database.
And somebody goes onto
a website and checks
the score of the World Cup
and sees, OK, it has finished.
And this country
won the World Cup.
And then the friend
that is sitting next
to you, you tell them like, hey,
this country won the World Cup.
And the friend is
going to the website.
But he's going to a different
replica of your NoSQL database,
and for him, the
game hasn't finished.
So the data hasn't
replicated to all replicas.
And so two people can
see different results.
In Cloud Spanner,
this cannot happen.
If the data has been committed,
all replicas have that data.
And so if any
requests are coming
in from all over
the world, everybody
will see exactly the same data.
The fourth question
is, does Cloud Spanner
have Client Libraries?
Yes, we do have
Client Libraries.
We have Client Libraries
for Node.js, Java, PHP,
Go, and Python.
And we are working on
a lot of other ones.
We have also C#.
We even have the C# ORM
connector already available.
And the fifth question was,
does Cloud Spanner encrypt data?
So Cloud Spanner, all the
data in flight and at rest
is encrypted on Cloud Spanner.
So if you load any of your
data in there at rest,
all the data is encrypted.
Now, if you want to have
encryption on top of that,
you need to put this
encryption on top of that.
While we're talking
about encrypting data,
I want to talk about
the permissions
that you can set
on Cloud Spanner.
So we have identity and
access management system
in Google Cloud Platform.
We call it IM.
And you can actually
set IM roles up
to the database
level, who is allowed
to access through
a database read,
write, and execute
queries, things like that.
All right.
See if you have some other--
OK.
Cool.
I think that's all the
questions that we had.
Do we have any other questions?
I see there are a couple
of other questions.
Should we answer
them or should we--
OK.
We're going to answer actually
the other questions offline.
We're going to answer them.
So please stay tuned.
If you have asked
any other questions,
we're going to definitely
answer them after this session.
The next session will come
out of our Kirkland office
in Seattle.
And Kirill Tropin is talking
about the right storage class
to optimize the performance
of your workload.
So please stay tuned for the
next session out of Seattle.
Thank you very
much for your time,
and I hope you
enjoyed this session.